I want to talk about what you guys find
is the best part of your jobs um for me
personally I think it's having an Avenue
to really deep dive and critique a game
and the way it's designed and the way it
plays it's um something that I found
that I've been doing before I started
working in this industry anyway and it's
part of the reason I actually sort of
sent in a sample first of all in the
first place so just having an an outlet
to have discussions with people who are
like-minded and and sort of critique and
examine things at that same level I find
is really
rewarding um there's a couple of things
I really enjoy I I wouldn't say it
straight afterwards but I actually
really enjoy E3 it's exciting what yeah
no I'm serious like it's it's really
nice catching up with all these people
on the other side of the world it's a
strange experience for 3 months
afterwards hat3 but leading up to it an
add3 it's a lot of fun um the other
thing that I'm really starting to enjoy
is making game inform for's page plan
which if you don't know it's basically a
document of all the pag in the yeah all
flat plan for those print guys all the
pages laid out on a flat surface and
it's just a Tetris puzzle deciding what
the magazine will look like ultimately
knowing where your ad pages are knowing
if this article should be a four pager
or a three pager and that sort of
evolves organically over the month and
it's really interesting when that starts
to come together and you get an idea of
what the Magazine's going to look like I
um I get a kick out of that how much are
you thinking about how much you like
that game and how much you think the
audience likes that game and wants to
read more of it I mean they're the two
factors that matter the absolute most
like nothing else comes into it and I
would say I mean our readers are
basically the average gamer so I do feel
like there's and I'm the average gamer
too I really do feel like there's a
massive crossover between what I like
and what our audience likes but yeah I
mean I really like Mortal Kombat so I'll
probably put a tiny bit more of that in
the magazine than Street Fighter you
like
everything I don't think I've ever heard
you say that game looks terrible like
I've never heard that come out of your
mouth yeah once we get off the stage all
right that is cool like one of the
things I really miss about working on
magazines is that bigger picture cuz you
have this product that you're making
whereas online is really like
there's a lot of charm to it you know
but as a magazine it's like wow what am
I going to create this month what's it
going to look like what's it going to
feel like the idea of s of imagining
what a reader is going to look like
going to feel like when he flicks this
page and what the experience is going to
be cuz like reading a magazine is an
experience whereas an online well still
an experience was a very different one
so I also really miss that sort of side
of like journalism in terms of print
versus online for sure yeah I feel that
way about print as well I love the um
just laying things out and making a
feature look stunning as well like
having that freedom to have a bit more
um creativity and artwork rather than
something that's online CU I do a bit of
online uh work as well where
everything's just kind of you're pouring
words into a template or in the mag
you've really got to think about how
much space you have and where things are
going to go but beyond that I mean I
love Yeah critiquing games Mark I know
that you kind of shy away from reviews
well look the truth is I hate video
games so why would I want to R no like
you're one of those fake gamer guys yeah
I'm a fake gamer guy uh I've written
more reviews in my lifetime and I and I
just don't care to write another one
ever you know like that's just always
been my my way and I I obviously love
video games um but writing about them
and the way Dan was discussing is is not
really something that interests me I'm
more interested in stories about people
who make games I'm more interested about
that sort of side of things I'm more
interested in R about business side of
games and more I just I just like I like
stories and I like telling people's
stories that's most important to me and
I think one of the things I look for in
potential journalist is not that how
much not not how much they love games
not how many games have played not how
good they are not how well they can
evaluate them you know how well can you
write how can you put it together how
can you how can you sp like a a story
how are you going to be able to to break
that news story you going to be able to
write that feature are you curious are
you professionally curious you know
that's what you need to be to be a
journalism a journalist a good
journalist at least in my opinion and uh
writing W about video games I'm just
this core about video games is just such
a small part of what my job is and uh I
think it's yeah it's important but it's
not the most important thing to me I'll
back that 100% it's much more important
to me that you know how to use commas
than how many hours you've played World
of Warcraft yeah for sure I don't like
people at all I don't I don't like
writing those kinds of stories I'm all
about sort of how the game functions as
I don't really think of them as art I
think of them as more of a craft and
sort of unpacking what is happening with
the way it's been designed and how that
can create a personal experience rather
than sort of stories about people around
video games themselves I don't know I'm
probably with you on that one I mean I I
I think it's important to
have uh I mean right is is having
something to say and saying it well
there's the the two elements to it and
sometimes we search for humanism when
there's there's not much to say but uh
um you know sometimes that's the most
interesting thing about it you got to
you spot what what is the most
interesting thing what you know what
could I possibly write this article
about usually for me it's taking that
game design angle and um I like
analyzing the the Dynamics and mechanics
uh working within a game but uh I mean
the the critiquing side and me being
able to focus on gameplay that's a close
second for me but the the actual
favorite part of the job for me is
speaking to people uh not so much
writing stories about them but just just
the very generous nature of developers
in this industry um they don't like to
hold back sometimes they've got a PR
person over their shoulder that are
making them hold back but they they like
to talk about what what they're making
and they're very generous with it and uh
when you are in a place like E3 and
there's a whole bunch of them together
and probably more so like GDC and stuff
like that there's just this Creative
Energy that everyone's sharing and
they're they're all talking about you
know what they're making and they're all
sharing ideas and and I do love being
around that that's probably my favorite
part although it is married with my
least favorite part which is
transcribing the interview later on yep
so just to go over it one of the coolest
things I've done was attending game jams
and for that exact same reason or that
Creative Energy I think one of the most
fun parts of being a games Journal
journalist is when you actually go you
know into a studio or you go into a
space where people create things and you
feel that energy and you feel that Vibe
and you feed off it and to me that's
very often where the real stories live
where you go in there and you know this
guy's been working on this one thing for
you know four years he's been focused on
this one tiny aspect of a game you know
what does it take to be that person what
does it take to have that kind of
commitment you know these are all the
things I'm curious about and I want to
rate about and yeah that that's just
such a beautiful thing to be involved in
in rate about I do feel very in that
regard like being able to go to the
studios and checking things out and
seeing yeah seeing the environment where
these things are made but also getting
to talk to the developers and even be
able to do it after the fact as well
like I spoke to the guys who worked on
um Forza Horizon 2 and we've um I think
all of us here would have seen Forza
Rison 2 already being kind of fortunate
to get the code um beforehand it is part
of the job as well um but then speaking
to Ben Penrose who's the art director
over there and just asking him the
process behind making the game and
backing it up with my own experiences as
well and just kind of getting his
stories about the things that that went
on and being able to do that is
amazing so I want to move on to what you
guys think the hardest part of your jobs
are um and I'll start with something
that's specific to my current role but
I'll add something after that I think
now that I've moved from a print medium
to an online medium uh being comfortable
in front of a camera is really difficult
because it's a really unnatural thing
when you're sort of first coming into it
and there's this sort of uh requirement
now from people who consume games media
that they want that personality behind
the writer and they want sort of that
raw connection with another person
whereas I usually like to hide behind my
words that's kind of why I started
writing you know you get time to say
exactly what you want whereas when
you're saying something on camera you
you get that sort of one chance maybe a
few takes whatever
um but in general one of the hardest
parts is that you just don't really have
time to play games as much as you would
think because there is a lot of actual
actual work that you're doing instead
whether it's writing following up with
contacts Publishers going out and
meeting people going to events doing
things like EV Expo the actual time you
have to play games is far far less than
you would think despite it being part of
your role to actually be playing games a
lot of the
time uh what's hardest hardest part of
the job is that okay I don't want to
winge too much cuz I'm very well aware
from the outside it looks like coming
home from the Ice Cream Factory and just
complaining about eating ice cream um
the hardest part for me is definitely
the hours when you we're approaching
deadline gaming for is a monthly
magazine and the workload goes like this
across the month the first week of the
month just answering emails I'm thinking
about what's going to happen watching
YouTube videos yeah watching YouTube
videos it's Facebook um the last week of
the month uh when we're subbing
everything it's you know it can be I'll
work through two weekends it'll be a 120
hour week and I'm at the point of
tearing my hair out at that at that
stage every single month um so yeah that
is that is absolutely the part of the
job I enjoy the least but that being
said it's still fun I'm still enjoying
what I'm doing it's exciting seeing the
magazine come together but yeah the
great thing is when you actually get
that physical copy of magazine at the
end of the print cycle you're kind of
like ah I try not to read them cuz as
soon as I open them I see mistakes they
just so yeah I since I started this job
I don't read game and bomber
anymore uh hardest part of the job I
guess I'm to consider the last eight
years um I I don't have to deal with
this so much
nowadays um but I guess when you're
reviewing a game when you're critiquing
a game um you know they say it's pretty
easy if if it's a really bad game or if
it's a really good game uh because in
terms of what to write um you're you're
you know you can you can have fun
slamming it or you can have fun you know
singing its Praises uh but they say it's
sort of those mediocre ones that that
are a bit harder to write about those
seven out of 10 that you still have to
come up with words for uh I don't know
that that's entirely true though because
when you when you come across a bad game
uh I mean people have spent a lot of
time making this game and crafting this
thing and they've they've poured their
lives into it so if you're going to pan
it you you need to be damn sure it's the
game's fault uh and not yours and that
means sometimes becoming a bit of a QA
tester so if you're planning on giving
something a three out of 10 or a 4 out
of 10 or something like that that means
testing every possible scenario making
sure uh it's not you uh and to use uh uh
I guess it's not too recent an example A
Rage to use rage as an example um that
game had technical flaws and I was
reviewing it on on PC and uh it was it
was quite a few late nights uh trying a
lot of technical configurations on my
computer to make sure it wasn't me it
wasn't my computer it was definitely the
game it happened to be released around
the same time that uh ATI released some
new drivers and that was kind of
stuffing it up but it basically meant
that about a third of the people in the
world uh the game would be on playable
for them and so it was a hard one to
review but I thought in the end you know
in Across The Wider spectrum of reviews
my score would would U filter in to
basically mean well yeah you know I'm
going to give it a very low score some
people are going going to give it a very
high score and across the wider Spectrum
everyone will be represented because a
lot of people won't be able to play it
but I had to go back and forth with the
publisher back and forth with the
developer um just to make sure uh it was
it was not my fault sometimes it's a
technical thing sometimes it's a design
thing sometimes it's reloading the game
and making sure OB did I just do this
wrong if it's a tower defense game and
am I just arranging my stuff wrong um so
you know it's it's playing a game so boo
freaking who right but um yeah it's it
can be a bit of work in in those times
when it's like you you're playing a very
bad game and uh you you need to play it
more actually because you you need to
make absolutely
sure if that makes sense absolutely yeah
um there's a lot of difficult things
with my job like I mean for a lot of
people the job seems like a dream job
but it is hard and we work hard we work
a lot of long hours and and um the most
difficult thing for me though probably
is like some of the ethical things you
have to consider like um especially if
you're breaking some sort of important
story that that could affect the
livelihoods of people and you have to
really consider and you have to do the
right thing in those circumstances
there's been times where I've broke news
about Studios closing down or or um you
know games being canceled or or even
like things that are a bit more shady
than that and it's just like you have to
be 100% right and then there's that risk
of you know something backfiring on you
you know you have to check your sources
you have to double check this you have
to speak to the right people a lot of
that's really difficult and can be
really high pressure especially if you
want to be first with that story and and
you have it like there was a very recent
story like that where I knew a couple
other people might have been on this
this story and I wanted to be first more
than anything cuz I've been working on
this story for months and months and
months and then you know waiting for the
confirmation emailing people playing
hard ball with certain like people who
who didn't want to talk and then that
sort of thing is really high high
tension high stress you know it's just
like you could be Beyond reproach in
your practice you have to be Beyond
reproach you have to cover your ass in
every single possible way you know like
do you doubt yourself much do do you
doubt yourself when you come times yeah
the one the one example that I really
doubted myself on was uh like kitaku
Australia was the first uh Outlet to
report that Destiny
existed and I was and I had this guy who
was telling me all about Destiny years
and years and years ago and uh I was
just like this is such a cool story oh
my God you know what this is what bung's
been working on this is the next big
thing and it was like I want to report
this right away right now I want
everyone I want everyone to read this
story and it's just but at the same time
I have to spend such a long time with
this guy you know double checking he
actually did work at bu it could be
anyone cuz you get [__] emails every
day you know H so that's that you doubt
yourself there and more than anything
you just want that second person to
confirm it and sometimes finding that
can be
absolutely nerra and impossible that
that's the most difficult part of the
job for me for
sure I think this is kind of coming
across all of us but having and sort of
echoing um Jeremy's words before but
that for me writers block when when
you've got a middling piece of crap that
you've got to write about and trying to
make it exciting if you've got a game
that is really really good or really bad
the wood just come out and it's like
you're just dancing around them and
everything just lays down nicely but
when you got something that you're stuck
with and it's just like this big
undefeatable block that you've got to
kind of create something around that is
kind of really really frustrating and
yeah deadlines as well playing something
under deadline um I'd say something like
review events
this is kind of peering behind the
curtain a little bit there's often times
when you go to a review event and
Publishers will throw you into a room
and go here's the game you go for it and
you know that you've got a certain
amount of time to get through something
and it's a matter of like playing
through and pushing hard and they give
you enough time to do it but you're
playing in a way that is quite a little
bit unnatural to how you're doing it at
home because I would stop and start and
i' kind of come back to things and there
be times when uh you be very addicted to
something and it's easy and you kind of
keep going other times he like I've had
enough but man I've got to I've got to
keep going I've got to going we got to
get the words in deadlines coming so on
and so on and that's kind of yeah it's
playing the game past the point where
it's fun where if you were playing it as
a consumer you go outside and kick a
football right about now and it's trying
not to hold that against the game cuz
it's not the game's fault that you have
a silly deadline that can be difficult
though cuzz I remember when I when I was
reviewing Assassin's Creed 2 I was in
the situation and Assassin's Creed 2 was
a weird one cuz the first game had
gotten such polarizing reviews you know
people loved it people hated it and the
second one was sort of like a big deal
for Ubisoft and and I like the first one
I played the second one under these
crazy intense circumstances and it was a
bit awkward and weird I remember because
um the Creator was like was wandering
around while I was playing it was just
in it felt a bit dodgy but it's kind of
fun as well I remember one point I'm
playing the game and I'm just like super
frustrated CU I keep getting I keep
dying at this point I'm just
like and then I turn around and he's
right behind me the career of the game
and he's like ah ah are you enjoying
yourself I'm just like just like that is
not conducive to an effective reviewer
at all and and in the end that ended up
negatively affecting my Assassin's Creed
2our review like I gave it a low score
than I should have done in hindsight
because that experience sucked and I
couldn't your attention to specific
things like notice how it goes into the
third person view here watch how the
grass sways in the breeze here or or the
was thing well this is all this is just
an ear version we're going to fix this
you know we're going to fix that and you
don't know what to believe cuz there
have been times where someone's told me
oh we're going to fix this it's it's
already fixed and then the retail
release comes in and lo and behold it's
not fixed so that happened with the
first Assassin's Creed for me so the
second one I'm just like no no Patrice
no and and and and the crazy thing was
when the game came out it was fixed yeah
so Pat screwed me like everyone screwed
me yeah two of the big ones recently I
think were uh Sim City and uh
Battlefield 4 they were both reviewed
under review conditions for a lot of
outlets and then when they went to the
wild you know the servers were terrible
the always online features were terrible
um I reviewed DAV X Human Revolution
over the course of 3 days in a dark room
in square enix's office why is always a
dark room I don't know but it was
probably the best 3 days of my life I
won't lie uh but yeah it's um it's it's
the kind of thing where you just
especially with any online features you
need to be in the Real Environment to
sort of give it a proper critique I
think I think a lot of meter Outlets are
actually starting to rethink their
review policy we we've basically been
talking amongst ourselves and we're
deciding it's much better to be right if
there is a right then be first and on
time and if that means reling a review
in a magazine sometimes that's
absolutely worth it we to do this with
Destiny this issue because we needed to
test it on the servers that you guys are
playing it on otherwise it's just not
representative that's even more of an
issue now with the um buying betas and
Early Access and that type of stuff
because it's it's very blurry line of
when a game is actually finished so you
get Early Access games that are pretty
much done you get Early Access games
that are way too early and now let's try
and have a policy on when can we
actually review this a lot of outlets
have said you know only when the game is
actually released do we review it but
sometimes by that point the whole hype
train is gone and no one's talking about
that game anymore everyone else already
had their reviews out ages ago so it can
be pretty tricky with that one I think I
think in general it just sort of shows
that reviews as they stand currently are
becoming slowly and slowly more
irrelevant like cuz because we have so
much access to them as consumers uh in
terms of trailers in terms of Early
Access be like you were saying you know
you know what the game plays like you
know who it's going to play you know if
it's you probably know legitimately
whether it's going to be be good or bad
before it comes out uh a game like
Destiny is a perfect example it's such a
weird game to review you know like
people have played it people hate it
people love it I mean to me Destiny
almost breaks the traditional review it
breaks it cuz people are giving it l
scores you know 67 blah blah blah
they're still playing it they're still
playing it more than the game they gave
9 out of 10 you know it's kind of it's
just a weird situation and as games
evolve and as media evolves I think the
review is just
like this that's that's one of the
reasons why I really back away from
doing them because I just think there's
just so much
involved in making a doing a review
right you know it's just very awkward
and difficult to sort of pass right now
yeah Destiny's des's a strange example I
was I was half expecting um Activision
to do some type of like review event
beforehand but then they went no we're
was going to launch it and reviews can
come in you know whenever they're going
to come in because yeah like it's all I
think the online things being online all
the the time is really going to disrupt
things but then there's that pressure
there to get a review up online as soon
as you can because people will still
search reviews even though as you said
like people have got um Early Access and
there's betas and so on and people do
know how the game is I think that people
still kind of want a familiar um
authorative review from from a
recognizable Outlet sorry hijack again
but like cuz games are an evolving thing
they they're not static entities anymore
like when I when I started playing video
games you bought the game you put it in
cartridge slot and it was a thing that
just sat there and that was that thing
for the rest of its life now it's a
thing that starts as a you know look at
Minecraft Minecraft will never stop
growing Minecraft will be growing
probably long after I'm dead you know
it's just going to that's not a static
game it's not a static thing so putting
this big stamp on it boom
87 it's just useless it's just I think
uh as as Internet improves and and as
streaming technology improves as well
this is looking more like 10 years down
the track or something like that um I
don't think reviews will ever be
completely redundant but um you know
you'll be able to try a game try the
demo of a game in your browser you know
similar to how Guai or or one of those
streaming uh Technologies allows you to
to just stream the game to your console
or to your PC or something like that
you'll be able to just try it in your
browser so instead of watching a
5-minute review why not try the tutorial
level just play it for 5 minutes you'll
know whether you like the game or not
well I mean that sort of Segways very
nicely into what I want to talk about
now which is how journalism is is is
evolving in reaction to the way games
were evolving as well uh and I mean when
I started in games journalism I didn't
have a Twitter account because I thought
it was silly and
now was silly social media is so
important now and things like live
streaming didn't
exist uh and demos were still a thing uh
so how have you guys seen journalism
change to sort of account for the way
games are
changing I guess I mean I almost need to
sit out of this question I feel like I'm
almost the exception to all these rules
that Game Informer is we're still oh can
you hear us from up there Mr Milner no
no I'm not I'm saying in many ways we
are just excluded from the way it's
going at the moment it's all about Let's
Plays and handson and we're a print
publication we sort of exist in our own
Niche so um I mean yeah you obviously
there's the move to
online and there's the move to more
Community engagement as well you see it
in a lot of what Nintendo's doing at the
moment I mean they talk they did a
Nintendo Direct Australia last week
they're talking straight to the
consumers and I mean I think that's
probably great for the community it's
not going to work with everyone but for
Nintendo that's a special case and I
think it makes sense that is the other
major thing as well is Publishers have
uh Avenues to speak directly to Gamers
they don't necessarily need to go
through press anymore are we useful
I don't know I feel pretty useful I
think there'll still always be a place
for us but but now you know there's
there's everyone can have their say so
you know you get things like uh user
review scores or or a bigger thing user
reviews or bigger thing uh but also I
think I mean that's kind of necessary
because um while while we will always
exist they are sort of needed to cover
the the much larger amount of games that
are coming out so I mean there's there's
more I mean when I when I was sort of
starting out you had people who could be
walking encyclopedias of every game that
was about to come out and every release
date over the next 6 months they could
actually be across everything now you
cannot get that you get a whole Outlet
of people who who literally cannot be
across all the indie games that are
being released and I think uh Ron Cari
was telling me in an interview that
70,000 games were released on the itan
store this year that's crazy and see
that needs to be its whole like Niche
which has niches within that you know
just the App Store and uh like then
you've got like the indie games on PC
and stuff like that so you need Outlets
like Niche Outlets to uh cover those
things and you need all the YouTube
channels like so I can sort of uh jump
on there and find a game that I like
because I you know I I'll spend a crazy
amount of hours in a tower defense game
or like frozen sign ups or something
like that and it's great that that many
games exist but I mean probably we could
do a bit better with the the curation of
of Target you know like putting that
game in front of me because maybe if I
wasn't if it wasn't my job to check like
literally everything that comes out then
maybe I wouldn't have come across that
that's a bit of a shame I think um one
of the things you mentioned Dan you know
about Nintendo going direct to Consumers
and Publishers ability to go direct to
Consumers now you know I don't think
that makes us irrelevant at all I think
that should we should see that as a
challenge to to to go beyond that
because back in the day when there was
no when there was no direct connection I
don't want I don't want to think of
myself as like some middleman that just
goes oh give me your marketing message
Nintendo you know that's that's not what
our job should be and the fact that they
can just go past us now should encourage
us to be like well wait a
minute that's not right that's unethical
that's
[__] this is actually what's
happening that's our job is to be like
not in the middle man our job is to be
like stand in the middle of it you know
like what the hell's going on here but
but as a response to that the public
sees so much more of a game before it
comes out now with so many trailers so
many sort of like first party
walkthrough videos that they're much
more likely to form their own opinion I
think based purely on that market
absolutely that's why that's why that's
one of the other reasons why I think
reviews are slowly becoming more more
and more IR relevant because like a role
used to be more of like an like an
arbitr you know it was like what's good
and what's bad more we'll tell you and
you can spend your money on the think is
good or bad I don't think that's where
our job should be now like my my job in
my opinion is
to tell stories about that are
compelling to you around culture of
video games and that's that's what
basically what kaku's mission as the
whole you know that's that's what so in
that sense it's evolved like that you
know uh it's more of a what's
interesting what's interesting about
this thing it's also about coming to
these you know coming to these games or
coming to these people with an angle you
know how are you going to tell their
story our job is to find a way to tell
that story in the most efficient and
most interesting way possible you do
still need people to I mean I think that
that is definitely necessary and and and
a great uh thing to do uh but like just
back on the subject of reviews you do
still need people to tell you what the
game's like at level 20 like does it
what's the end game like and that's part
of like you know you get those those
Niche uh YouTube channels that will only
cover something like Dark Souls um but
reviewers should be doing that as well
absolutely that's why I like I love your
work so much like I love
D the floppy man yeah
the so devastated that the floppy was
gone because that was more than just oh
this game's pretty good it was really it
really was like what you wanted to be
which is like a really in depth like
hard game a week yeah I mean that's
definitely still valuable I would never
say that's not valuable I'm just saying
that you know in general I feel
like the review you weren't reviewing
games like like like I used to review
games you know what I mean it's just a
different thing don't you feel though
that like I mean in terms of taking a
marketing message and just delivering it
to the public that we in Australia have
have sort of needed to do better than
that anyway because we typically get the
message later than the rest of the world
anyway I mean we would all get emails in
our inbox uh a press release 3 days
after the news already broke overseas
so uh you know it's kind of already
pollinated all across the internet and
we've reported on what the American
sites have reported on and so our reason
to exist has always been something else
like whether it's having an interesting
opinion on that or a little bit further
investigation like Australian Outlets
have always had had to have that little
something extra anyway to even be there
yeah I agree yeah I think people kind of
tune in to uh to what we're doing it's
more so about like personalities I mean
it was always about having like a
magazine or identif playing with someone
who had a personality you wanted to uh
like to be around but you look at uh
YouTube like let's plays and so on like
that and people will follow YouTubers
and let's plays based on how they are
and how they can identify them and how
they're being entertained as well and I
think the gamees journalism is really
about you know entertaining people as
well as informing them but definitely a
big skew on the entertainment side of
things and those YouTubers aren't giving
game scores out of 10 you know and
they're still building massive following
so obviously that's something Works um I
would definitely like to see us move
away from the news preview review cycle
like more in-depth critique can happen
after the game has come out uh talking
to the developers about why they did
certain things and yeah I think we're
all basically in agreement that that
would provide a richer games journalism
richer more interesting content for
consumers I think it's also worth saying
I think games journalism right now is is
is way better than it's ever been before
we're at a massive High Point right now
I think we get critic
we're very
corrupt I know I don't even want to go
there but like I think we're just cuz of
the internet and explosion the internet
man it's like we've got so many Niche
Publications talking about Niche
interesting things and everyone covering
all these different things the spectrum
is just exploded before it was a
magazine with the news reviews preview
cycle and that was that was interesting
for then but I mean now we have
everything now we have people WR about a
million different things and it's cool I
think you're right content wise but I'd
like to see it be a golden age for
people getting paid for it as well
absolutely man jeez oh and on that note
I got to get paid what advice would you
guys have for people who want to get
into games journalism um I would say
what we were just talking about before
have a niche and by that I mean be the
best strategy game guy or or girl be the
best RPG person have an area of
expertise that you can own and show
people that you can own that if you're
trying to be a broad Strokes person like
hey I want to review a game give me a
game to review that doesn't work anymore
you know you have to have a reason to be
the best at
something um we've touched it before but
persistence is a key thing and it is
largely related around some of our
workloads if if you catch me in my down
week I always respond to you because an
editor did that to me and I feel like I
owe it to everybody else to do that too
if you catch me in deadline week there's
a very good chance that that email will
just get ignored just out of
practicality if anyone here has emailed
me and I didn't responded please email
me again next week not this week um so
yeah persistence get our names right in
the emails get the name of the
publication right in the emails and also
attach attach a document with reading
don't send as an email saying can I send
you an email that's just an extra step
just send it and I will absolutely look
at it I think we all will
um yeah I guess well my number one tip
would be what what you said Dan uh with
the the funding your nation funding your
specialty it's uh it's very valuable to
an editor if uh you know they don't have
anyone in the office like what I was
saying before when you have an entire
outlet but they they just cannot be
across everything so there might just
not be the person in the office who can
do racing games you know who's there
might just be no one who's good at them
or uh there might be just no one who
knows how to cover a military Sim so uh
I mean it's very valuable if you can
email an editor with with you know
saying this is my specialty i' I'd also
like to write more about this and that
um but I guess to uh to throw another
one in there um who you have beers with
is pretty important um you know it
really is get getting out to a
networking event uh once you you know go
to your first couple and you can talk to
a few people get to know them uh let
them know what you're about uh don't
don't be like a hanger on or anything
but just just try to you know be
friendly and and be honest and uh just
let them you want to do more of this and
that's it's one of the best things you
can do uh a lot of people I mean it's a
small industry everyone knows everyone
so um you can go to an event meet meet a
lot of people give them your card um
yeah I think it's important that you're
good be good uh and I think it's I mean
but most most specifically I think you
have to be good at writing and you have
to read a lot and you have to want you
have to want to evolve your writing your
what you you're writing skill and what
you do and I think it's super super
super important to be professionally
curious to be like to practice curiosity
to look at something and say well I
wonder what this person would say about
that I wonder what the angle what the
best angle to for this story would be
you know you have to really you want
have to want to be a writer and you you
have to want to be a Storyteller it's
like 100% the most important thing I
think about being a journalist your
office is really good for that by the
way cuz you've got like several curious
people all in one little pod you've got
like the Gizmodo editor a couple Life
Hacker editors and uh the publisher
right there and as soon as you say
something to that office you've got
multiple curious people all providing
their own angle of curiosity on that so
that's just such a rich and not just
that like like so many times that
there's just there's just stuff I don't
know what to do right for example the A
C is taking valve to court I've never
done Court Reporting before I have no
goddamn idea what I'm doing but there
are people in that office I've done that
before and they're telling me what to do
basically step by step like I'm a puppy
on a leash and it's really helpful to me
to to have that sort of advice so that's
another cool thing surround yourself
with people who know what they're doing
surround yourself with people who can
help you and who can mentor you that's
also super important so if you're
getting in touch with any of us here um
try and make our jobs easier because
anyone that you contact in any type of
media organization is always busy
there's always something they're trying
to do and when I get emails from people
wanting to do uh work for the mag and
this is true on Xbox it was true on
Playstation magazine just when you're
writing a pitch if you got an idea if
think youve got a killer idea make sure
it's something that either hasn't been
done before or make it the best that it
can possibly be or just make it like a
slight tweak on something that's
happened and make it the absolute
shining best example it can be as well
and this is true if you're going no
going to go for a job in meteor in games
or motoring or travel or anything like
that think about your elevator pitch
which is just can you sum it up in 10
seconds and just make it impactful
within the first couple of sentences
don't waffle around cuz if I'm reading
something reading reading I'll get back
to this later and I won't get back to it
because I've got a thousand other things
that are going on I think that's the
coolest advice like learn to pitch man
learn to pitch really good interesting
stories and learn to do it in two
sentences man Boom the thing that'll add
to being good is you really only get
good by writing don't contact us before
you've written anything you need to
write and you need to critique your own
work you need to show it to your friends
and you need to be able to take that
feedback on and not be offended by it
someone might not like your first our
first pieces were all terrible I'm mine
were I haven't read your first pieces
definitely be able to my piece was
fantastic thank you very much fantastic
sorry second piece terrible but same
with videos I mean they I think they say
like uh takes I mean um it's probably
just an average but probably about seven
videos before you make a good one like
and that's just internet videos like um
just you know if you're making a YouTube
channel and stuff like that even if
you've already got all your equipment
and stuff like that there's just so many
obstacles to overcome and then little
blips that you have to that you haven't
thought about it gets about your seventh
video that you go okay that was all
right that was workable so plan ahead
like that don't don't try and make your
first one your actual first one have we
got time for a
Q&A all right just if you have a
question just put your hand up we have a
microphone coming
around uh do you want to pick for me
because I can't yeah there's a little
light don't
mind okay I think this hand may have
been up
first hi um sorry my question is
um um obviously what you do is you you
take what you do as a career and it's a
profession so you have to be
professionals um is this something that
you see yourself doing for the rest of
your profession or do you have secret
aspirations for I'm going to burn out
real soon so I think the thing about
games journalism is that it's not well
established enough to be a lifelong
career choice yet what you see is a lot
of people moving into areas that
surround it so uh there's things like uh
public relations working for one of the
games companies itself becoming a game
developer uh I'm not so sure journalism
uh it can be a lifelong career but you
are going to be uh probably Limited in
ways that are going to start to bug
you how do you mean what are those
limiting ways then I I think uh
financially and I think in ways that
don't allow you to grow Beyond a certain
uh level as a writer or just as uh a
professional yeah I feel I feel as a
have a glass SE on now you especially in
Australia you just hit it I feel like I
hit it very early and it's been very
frustrating to me you know like what
what do you do now to answer your
question I think it's important that
that we have old games journalists I
think that's so important because we're
all young and stupid We Don't Know Jack
[__] about life or anything so I think
it would be really cool to have a really
old games journalist I want to maybe
I'll be that guy you want to be the
David Stratton of games jourm yes 70
something years old and still playing oh
man halflife 23 is amazing I'll be that
guy I also think it depends how you're
approaching this if you're coming from
it from a I like games point of view or
an I like writing point of view and so
people with the games they might do PR
I'm personally coming from it from a
writing point of view if I
if I end up if I stopped doing this I'd
probably try and transition into
mainstream media just writing about
something else what's really cool is
that there are so many avenues for
people who are in it for the writing a
lot of games writers I'm seeing are
releasing their own ebooks or like long
form criticism which they're selling as
independent Publications uh and there's
there's always going to be something
that you can sort of bring your Niche to
and try and and and build uh a following
through that as well I really like what
you do with uh the sneaky bastards thing
man something like that that really
appeals to me like what you do there was
really cool that was exhausting but uh
really personally fulfilling I think
yeah thank you yeah um I'll I was just
going to finish off um I do other things
as well so I've done murdering stuff
I've work for men's mags and that's
something that I can see myself going
into um at some point but I'll keep
going with this for as long as I love it
and having a lot of fun at the moment
and it is an industry we have a lot of
fun
in one
here uh hi guys um hello so my question
is uh if you've got like a product like
a game or an app or something that you
want to get to you guys and want to get
out there and stuff like that uh what's
the best way to approach you guys about
it um like to get you to into it get you
to it uh you have
to make sure it is something that we
already cover uh when I was on PC power
play we had a lot of people emailing us
about their iPhone games and we don't
cover iPhone games so that's step one um
step two uh I think we sort of covered
this a bit before like almost like
pitching a piece of writing just switch
the writing out for the game make it
concise put a screenshot in there put a
link to a YouTube gameplay video in
there give us a reason that you think
the game is exciting don't just tell us
what it is tell us something cool that
can happen in the game and
beyond that you just sort of have to let
the game speak for itself I think the
one minute uh oh sorry the one minute
gameplay video is very important uh and
also uh you know if you got some
screenshots to send us or a very quick
description of what the game is having a
place that people can land on the
internet if they search for the game and
instantly know what it is um I would
think of it like you know if you're uh
an indie versus as opposed to like a AAA
sort of game that's being released they
can control their hype cycle by you know
spending money spending money spending
money
on a curve like up to its release
whereas with you without that sort of
funding need to think of it like uh
giving writers content content content
content so you need to think of it uh as
having like four or five different
weapons uh different hooks uh that
people will want to write about so um
one of those might be you know just just
how interesting the game is just what
the hook of the game is another one of
those uh might be how it ties into a
certain event like if it's a sailing
game it's around the Cy robart time uh
another one of those and probably the
biggest one there there's several that I
could go through but probably the
absolute biggest one that you have is
your own personal story um that's uh
something that that uh it's completely
unique to you and no matter how boring
you think it is people will want to
write about it um doesn't have to be one
of the the alltime you know like oh I
mortgaged my house to pay for this game
development or anything like that uh but
uh you know you send an email like that
to Mark and he'll he'll jump all over
it's exactly he he's really kneeling it
right now man that's exactly it for me
personally also just as a bit of advice
there's a guy called Lance McDonald and
he's here and he's shown his game black
Annex and he is by far the best at this
that I've ever encountered this guy
would not leave me alone and he came at
me with his story a million times and he
was he is amazing at this this his
massive strength so he you can find him
I think he's at the homeg grown stand go
and find go look for Lance tell Mark
sent you to tell you how to pitch a game
article to editors and he will help you
man he's an awesome guy and a tiny bit
of a personal touch in your reaching out
to his email it does actually make a
difference cuz we get a whole lot of
press releases and a lot of them get
ignored and if it says hi all you know
it's insert name here yeah because we
all like Mark said we all want to get a
story first and we want to know that
you've re we want to think that you've
reached out to us not absolutely
everybody it might make us more keen to
jump on that story we want to feel
special man it might be something that
we need to reply to if I see an email
that says Dear Jeremy I I click on it
more yeah any else someone down the back
here guy can we get guy he's
he's hi um to all of you recently there
was an event in the industry known as #
closer to you okay cheers um there was
an event known as uh gamergate where um
Zoe Quinn and a person from Kotaku were
in a relationship and that wasn't fully
disclosed to the people reading the
reviews and the messages and whatever it
was and um then there was uh Anita
sarkeesian and feminist frequency and
basically those two kind of took off on
the
internet and um yeah it was kind of an
issue like that a lot of people covered
like um someone who I watch frequently
um Jim Sterling was all on that and he
wasn't happy about it and I know a lot
of people weren't happy about it but the
thing was that basically every news
media Outlet was covering it like
intensely and there was just nothing
else like I saw a wall full of posts
that were just Onis Arian and Zoe Quinn
so what were your responses to that
personally and like I think that uh
people's private lives aren't really
anyone's business uh and if it is
something that affects
their work it is their responsibility to
disclose it if they haven't then theyve
determined that it doesn't affect their
work um as far as niia sarkeesian goes I
really like her videos and I think she
makes a lot of really good points um I I
don't really uh post about them because
I'm I'm not much of a a news guy and I
haven't really seen the you were saying
like a wall of posts about people
covering it um I haven't actually
seen that so I can't really comment on
it more than that unfortunately the
story became the abuse like the the
actual I don't think anyone really
objects to sarkeesian offering her bit
but um like I mean the the story became
the abuse that she experienced and oh
are you talking about the bomb threat oh
well and the many messages that she you
know just the general abuse that the
that both of them had to deal with like
you know in terms of uh uh Zoe like I
don't think there's much there like
people it's a you Small industry people
hook up people meet each other there's
not too much there but but when that
that abuse happens of those people then
that became the story um and yeah you
know it's it's a shame that uh it became
a bit like two sides versing each other
and and probably most people caught in
the middle and I think a lot of sides
probably made the wrong decision
declaring Gamers dead and stuff like
that which was very adversarial and very
US versus them but um I think it's a
it's a bit behind us now I think people
are starting to realize what we need is
is less US versus them and and more
Reaching Across The Line in the Sand and
saying hey you know we all enjoy games
harassment is bad can we all just agree
on that I I I think there are a couple
of very valid issues that it absolutely
worth talking about out of this but when
it all gets piled up into this one giant
conspiracy theory of abuse and language
going both directions it's not conducive
to those conversations I mean I do my
person line is that if there is a
conflict of interest you just can't
cover that game if there's some personal
relationship some Financial relationship
you just you exclude yourself from that
coverage full stop like and if we had to
do that I'm an example of that J is an
example of that I've done work for bco
which meant I couldn't cover dark souls
and I really wanted him to write that
review because I think he's the guy to
write that review but he done work for
Namco so it was just absolutely not
going to happen um but the other side of
that is the abuse I mean none of us want
to see that and I also think it is a
really small minority I get amazing
letters from our readers I just think we
have a really intelligent thoughtful
community and it can really snowball on
the internet I don't generally think
that's reflective of everybody here the
whole thing just brought me down it's
like just be good to each other like why
are you being dicks just don't do that
just be just be good I felt a bit like
it was going both ways like I don't see
I don't like to see people talking down
to people no matter which direction it's
coming from
true also what do you think about hype
in the video game industry like Watch
Dogs was hyped up so much and that was a
disappointment to so many people as well
as Destiny cuz that was hyped up to be
one of the best games of the year and
yet it was meant to very mixed reception
part of uh the pack that I think
journalists and readers make with each
other is that we are going to provide
new details about a game when it comes
out but but I think the onus is on the
reader to control their reaction to that
or to measure their reaction to that
when it comes across and it's being used
with language that is high and floaty
and and I guess conducive to that kind
of hype that's something I have a
problem with
but quite often readers can also draw
their own conclusions based on the just
Avalanche of material that Publishers
can release which we do cover and it's
it's something that I think it's just
valuable as a gamer and a fan of gaming
to kind of keep your expectations in
check and just sort of realize that if a
game sounds cool that's kind of all you
need to know about it and then you're
going to check it out when it comes out
you're going to have a much fun more fun
time with things I'm jumping ahead a
little bit but could halflife 3
unconfirmed confirmed ever ever get like
a a proper like Fair appraisal do you
think uh good question when it comes out
or Well yeah if like I think that it's
it's not going to be the same situation
as Duke Nukem Forever because it's
obviously a thing that is still
happening and it's still being worked on
but I think the reason it hasn't come
out yet is because it wouldn't have
been and that's something that's Val is
going to have to deal with
and I I feel like they know what they're
doing
I think I don't know it's impossible to
tell should be talking about half lifee
yeah okay I think that is unfortunately
all we have time for so who wants to be
a games journalist after that I do and
who wants to stalk Mark I do as well
s thanks for coming put your hands
together for our panelist and thank you
very much for listening thank
you